This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we're going to be talking about cortisol. We're going to be talking about the hidden and in-depth impact that this stress hormone has on our bodies, on our minds, our cognition, and even things that you might not think about, like your emotional intelligence, our creativity, our relationships. You have probably been
hearing a lot about cortisol recently and your interest may or may not be. be peaked. So I want this episode to be a bit of a 101 psychology guide to A, what cortisol is, B, what it does and why it's important. See what happens when it becomes dysregulated. And more importantly, how to sustainably manage your stress response and lower your risk of chronic stress so that dysregulated cortisol hopefully doesn't become a problem for you. There is a lot of stress to be experienced in our 20s. I'm sure I don't need to tell you that because, you know, this period of our life is so uncertain and at times unstable, but it also feels very unnecessarily urgent, as if we have to have it all figured out right now, this instant, and all of these expectations in this
external, but also internal pressure, creates the perfect conditions for us to be in emergency mode. maybe more often than we need to be. And so understanding what happens to our bodies when that's the case or also when we experience great environmental stresses, like illness, like a breakup, like something terrible or traumatic, it's really important to know what's going on behind the scenes when it comes to your stress response. So that that doesn't become the dominating state for you.
There's also a lot of misinformation online about cortisol that I want to break down. Some of the myths I've heard recently are that cortisol is always bad for you, that you shouldn't do intense exercise because it increases cortisol. Your cortisol levels, you know, they can be controlled by processed sugar. You need to cleanse. You need supplements, et cetera, et cetera. But I think that the answer is a lot more simple and the more you know about just the very basics of cortisol, the more you can make informed choices. So that is our plan for today. let's talk all things cortisol and the experiences you may or may not know are associated with
this widely talked about but often misunderstood hormone, but also how you can manage your stress levels in the most simple, basic ways in your 20s. All of that and more on the psychology of cortisol. Without further ado, let's get into it. Let me start out by saying something maybe rather obvious and that is that cortisol gets a bad rap. Truly, it is demon and, it is demon by people for so many things, especially online, where people talk about cortisol face, cortisol weight gain, how to reduce your cortisol using oranges or some secret herbal recipe that only they can sell to you. I even saw a video the other day titled How to Get Your Cortisol Levels to Zero, which
honestly, it made me laugh. I sent it to a few friends because that is the complete opposite of what you want. You know, there is just so much misinformation around this hormone. So let's quickly myth bust this idea that cortisol is singularly bad for you. Cortisol actually plays a really essential role in your body, a vital one. Obviously, it's known as the stress hormone because of its part in helping us feel alert and energized and able to respond to danger, like a car racing towards you or a vicious dog, or some deadline or even internal stresses, like repetitive thoughts.
and, you know, a fear of failure. Cortisol's association with stress, which we typically see as bad, is probably why it gets a bad reputation and, you know, why it's demonized. But it actually is really important in helping us handle the big, scary, nerve-wracking things that we encounter in our daily life. And without it, we would not be able to act or respond to really anything in our environment in a way that was appropriate. some people often the second misconception is that adrenaline and cortisol are the same because they
do work pretty closely together when it comes to arousal and our stress response but the main difference is that adrenaline is what triggers your flight or fright response it is the first responder it is the police car at the scene it gets your heart pumping your pupils dilated your blood pressure up but cortisol is what comes in as backup it's the paramedics it's the ambulance your cortisol is there for the recovery, it's there for the long game, it's there to make sure that your response to whatever situation is alarming you is sustained. So really what it's responsible for is the long-term stress response. So your hypervigilance, making sure you are still alert to potential new threats,
making sure your body can get enough glucose and can use that glucose, helping your body break down fats, protein, carbs, which essentially is what allows you to have energy, not just in the aftermath of a crisis, but during your day-to-day. So what I'm really trying to say is that we really actually need it. Let's imagine you did lower your cortisol levels to almost zero, as that video I saw the other day was suggesting,
you know, if you didn't have enough cortisol available in your body, to really just put it, quite frankly, you would die. Like, that's it. It's called adrenal insufficiency. and it's life-threatening. Like you would go into shock, you wouldn't be able to move, you wouldn't really be able to respond to anything. So you do need cortisol, plain and simple. Even though it has that negative association with stress, we also know that stress isn't wholly bad either.
But the problems begin to occur when your body cannot regulate the level of cortisol. We'll talk about what that does to your body in a second, but we need to discuss why it happens. So the biggest culprit here is chronic stress because it causes our cortisol levels to remain high even when the thing in our environment or the internal stressor has passed. So chronic stress is like a rather broad descriptor here. It contains many events, situations, things, but I want to give you some examples of what could cause us to be in this state. A big one is long-term financial problems maybe. There was a study from 2013 that found that,
financial strain increases daily cortisol output and, you know, a lot of us are experiencing the cost of living crunch that's likely making our baseline level of stress increase. If you have a demanding high-pressed job, that's also going to contribute or even not having a job at all on the other side of the spectrum. You can see why that sometimes might feel tricky to navigate. What's another few examples? Tense and difficult relationships, whether that's romantic, platonic, familial that can bleed into your mental health and increase cortisol levels because you feel
stressed in response to your emotional and social environment, even health problems. Like if you have a chronic illness or a serious injury that has impacted your physical functioning, that's going to increase cortisol and major life events. So death, divorce, a breakup, all of those have a lingering emotional impact that can disturb our emotional homeostasis. So the one important thing to remember is that stress, although it sometimes helps motivate us, it helps us get shit done, it is not meant to be experienced constantly. And when it is, this means that the system in our body responsible for secreting all types of hormones,
it's called the HBA access, it remains overactive. And it's not necessarily getting the cues from our body to slow down, to pump the brakes, Over time, what this does is it desensitizes cortisol receptors and it disrupts the body's natural feedback mechanisms. So a feedback mechanism is basically there are little, I don't know how to explain it. Like there are little watchtowers, little gates in our body that are meant to be like, oh, okay, we've got too much here. Send it back. Send it back. Lower it down.
Increase, like almost like little markers, little test areas that your body is able to use. to respond to levels of cortisol. But when they become too desensitized or whatever it is, they don't start giving the right feedback. So that can either result in something called hypersecretion, so too much cortisol, or the opposite, low levels, which is hyposecretion. So hyper versus hypo.
How I really like to imagine hypersecretion, which is really what we're focusing on today, it's like you're behind the wheel of a car and your shoe gets jammed over the accelerator. and you are trying really hard to keep your eyes on the road, you're going so many miles an hour, you're trying to navigate traffic lights, navigate, you know, navigate stop science, and there's a bus full of children, you want to avoid that, there's a lake, you don't want to fall into it. You're trying to keep your eyes focused on what is actually happening,
whilst also trying to get your shoe unjammed. And that's the impossibility of dealing with high cortisol induced by chronic stress. you have to both deal with the impacts of high cortisol whilst also trying to reduce the stress at the same time. You have to try and keep your eyes on the road, but also, you know, look down to try and get the shoe off the pedal. So some other causes of high and dysregulated cortisol include an overactive pituitary gland. This one's actually very, very common. Sometimes it can be due to like tumors or growths, but also medications like steroids, also some form of birth control. I actually looked into this because I hadn't heard of that before.
I hadn't heard about the relationship between birth control and cortisol. And there definitely needs to be more research done on it. But there was a 2024 case study conducted by a doctor at UCLA that found that some oral contraceptives increase cortisol level in patients. He measured this by testing cortisol levels before and after the use of an oral contraceptive for two months and found that there was an almost three. 100% increase, 26 milligrams over the normal range after this person began to go back on their birth control. So it doesn't mean to like go off your pill right away or that your pill is making you stressed, although I think a lot of women would tell us, like there are huge emotional differences that I notice because the pill is influencing hormones and that is what cortisol is. But again, yes, not about trying to convince you to just go cold turkey on something that's very, very important for your health and your reproductive health in other areas, but it is an important factor to really think about.
If you have just gone on the pill and you've noticed anxiety spiking, could this be a contributor? But also, if you are already prone to chronic stress and you're already work in a really intense industry, you're drinking three to four coffees a day. you can only really unwind with alcohol, all of these things are going to be compounding. They're going to be compounding factors on your mental, emotional, cognitive state. And the reason why is because of the influence they have on cortisol and the influence they have on how our body responds to stress. Some other factors that contribute to high cortisol, conditions like depression and anxiety have also been associated with elevated cortisol levels.
However, it's important to note the direction of this relationship. It's kind of hard to pin down, right? How do we know whether you are anxious because you have elevated cortisol or your anxiety is causing cortisol levels to spike, right? It's very hard to tell. Most researchers would say, actually, it's a very intertwined system, anxiety, high cortisol. Although we don't know the relationship, we do know, they often go hand in hand. This is kind of a very quick summary of what contributes to a spike in this stress hormone.
And it's important to note that there is no way of escaping the impact this will have on your body. Humans are very strong creatures, but we are also still creatures. And no creature can survive under conditions of acute stress for a long period of time. Health does decline. Mental well-being does decline. You even see small things like hair and skin quality start to fade. Like you start to see someone's skin become quite grayish. Their hair starts to fall out.
All signs of like a sickness. And that sickness in this instance is coming from stress. Obviously those are some intense examples. Let's talk about what the hidden impact of excessive cortisol might look like on a smaller scale. Firstly, I'm going to touch on some of the non-obvious effects that you may not have heard about yet. The first big one is that high levels of cortisol dampen your emotional intelligence. So you're less able to respond not only just to your own emotional states, but also you're less able to recognize and appropriately respond to others. It's why you may become snappy.
You may suddenly realize you're saying things you don't mean and you didn't quite realize that you were saying them, that you're just exhausted and tired and sad and if someone asks you why you can't tell them because you haven't been able to see or notice any cause and effect between situations and your emotions because your emotional intelligence has been compromised. Here's another interesting impact. There was a 2014 study that found that elevated cortisol actually shifts our response to risk so that we become more cautious and guarded when it comes to anything from financial decisions to career to relationship decisions. It can make it so that when we see opportunity,
we feel like the likelihood of that opportunity being realized is reduced. So we're less likely to take risks. We're less likely to bet on ourselves. It's why people who are in chronic stress states find it harder to, you know, take the leap to start a business or to go back to school or to try something new. stress intertwines not just with health but with decision making as well. Here's another kind of scary realization or impact of high cortisol that makes us more pessimistic and it makes us less creative. So if you are someone who loves making art, you love creating
things, that important creative process and that ability to come up with new ideas spontaneously and execute them, it will decline when you are in a stressed state. because you cannot thrive during acute stress. It's why the secret to being more creative is and always will be, rest and novelty over discipline and routine and overworking. Because in the former lander conditions, there is just not enough room for your brain to explore different areas of itself. So those are some of the impacts you may not have heard of,
but here are some of the ones that you may already have a sense might occur to someone who's experiencing high cortisol levels. The first one is rapid weight gain. So high cortisol levels triggered by chronic stress, they increase our appetite and cravings for high calorie fatty foods by stimulating the release of appetite, regulating hormones. So let's talk about why this is the case. Obviously cortisol is released in response to stress. And if the body is stressed, it's thinking this is an emergency situation. This is a situation that we want to endure and survive. and if we're going to survive it, it means we should have as many resources as possible, including the energy stores that are necessary.
How do we bulk up or increase energy stores as a resource by eating more? So your body is literally saying almost like, almost preparing for like not the, not hibernation, but the opposite, like preparing to fight, to run away, preparing to hunger down and endure whatever chronic stress is currently playing out in your life and on your mind. It can also lead to what we call food noise. This is like an intrusive, constant thought about food because your body is, of course, trying to consume more energy and trying to find a way to motivate you or influence you to do so.
Here's another, a third effect of this. A third reason why people who are experiencing chronic stress often complain about weight gain. It's that cortisol promotes. fat storage, especially in the abdominal region, by increasing insulin resistance and altering how fat is distributed in the body. Again, your body is saying, we need this. This is DefCon 1. We're in an emergency situation. Let's get our stocks up. Elevated cortisol levels also slow down the metabolism. So together, these effects create a cycle of stress-induced weight gain. It's so hard when I hear
people or see people talking about their experience of just almost suddenly gaining weight for no reason and in such an unfair way like they're doing everything that they think they should be doing they're really healthy people they eat really well they have a really active lifestyle and they're still gaining weight in a way that feels like their body is working against them and you know weight isn't a terrible thing. It's not a bad thing. It's not something that should be avoided at all costs. But when it just appears to happen sporadically and spontaneously and nothing about your lifestyle has changed, it can be rather frustrating. It's why anytime I see someone like getting trolled on Instagram or TikTok for weight gain, you best believe, like I'm leaving a comment on their behalf because you really have
no idea what's happening in their life to cause that, let alone suggesting that, you know, suddenly they should feel a shame because their body is responding to perhaps a really intense situation or an emotional or external environment of intense stress or loss or grief or whatever it is they're going through. The human body is so much more complex than just calories in and calories out. And I don't know when we as a society will really start to understand that. You may also experience this kind of in the similar vein a bit different. increased inflammation, especially in the face. And this is this idea that you may know of as moon face.
That's where this has come from. So moon face is kind of like a colloquial way to describe the puffiness and appearance that our face gets when cortisol has just regulated, has been dysregulated for too long. So you often will begin to lose definition and features. It looks like your face is literally swelling up and looking like a big, round moon and this occurs because our body is holding onto more fluid and salt because cortisol is not properly regulating these deposits or is not properly regulating our insulin levels which is causing us to hold onto fat in these stores in our face again this can become a big point of
insecurity for people especially since you know our face is often the first thing people see and so when we can't recognize it anymore and we experience a drastic change that can cause a lot of insecurity, sometimes even a bit of an identity crisis. I don't think that's a vain thing to experience. Our physical form and our characteristics do help us define ourselves. So when they suddenly change without us really realizing how or why and we get this puffiness, we can really struggle. Those are just some of like the first consequences or impacts that come to mind.
I'm going to take a quick break here because I feel like I've just been throwing information at you. When we return, we're going to talk about some of the further impacts on things like sleep, like our relationships, like our, of course, anxiety levels, but also how we can address this and some of the lifestyle changes that may be floated to you by a doctor or by a psychologist. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break. down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and, conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies. In her story, this began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepin and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. All right, I want to touch on one final
consequence or impact of high cortisol that we may notice in ourselves before we get into my tips and advice. And this big consequence is the impact of high cortisol on sleep. Specifically something we call morning anxiety. Morning anxiety has to be one of the worst forms of anxiety. You know, all of them are actually pretty bad. But morning anxiety, you know, if I had to choose my favorite or my least favorite, it definitely takes the cake. So imagine you're restful, you're in bed, you're cozy, you're dreaming nice dreams, you're asleep, you're just feeling very, very peaceful. And then suddenly you are wide awake, heavy breathing, racing heart.
You instantly feel uneasy for no particular reason. And it's like, okay, here we are battling through another day of this. That is morning anxiety, is going from being restful to just being completely anxious and, I don't even know how to explain it. Like you wake up and your body is almost shaking. And it feels like you're just waking up to a completely energized body that you had no awareness of. And suddenly you're like 50% dipped into like a boiling pot of water and you have no idea
how you got there. That's what morning anxiety feels like. And being alert when you wake up isn't a bad thing. In fact, that's one of cortisol's useful functions. It's meant to actually peak or. spike in the morning to help you get out of bed and to help you get up and active and ready. But sometimes that cortisol awakening response can become skewed and not work properly. Chronic stress obviously contributes to that.
It leads to elevated cortisol levels at night because we feel like we can't switch off, which then has lingering effects till the morning. So not only are you not going to get good sleep, but you're also going to feel a sharp cortisol spike. cortisol spike right before you wake up. And that's going to create, not just take that natural alertness that you're meant to feel in the morning and turn it into anxiety. And of course, like the ball doesn't even stop there.
2018 study found that when you have a bad night's sleep, you already are at risk of higher levels of anxiety the next day, which you guessed it is going to make it so much harder to sleep the next night. And it just becomes a cycle of, okay, I can't sleep. I'm anxious, but then when I finally get to sleep, my sleep isn't any good, and then I wake up really anxious the next morning because those cortisol levels have carried over, but also because I had a bad night's sleep. So I'm extra anxious. How do you think that's going to help you or help your body? It doesn't, and it honestly has such lingering effects in all other areas of your life.
You're cranky, you have that mild feeling of irritability constantly, you can't process information as well, you feel slow. In a study from 2013, researchers observed people's IQs after a good night's sleep versus a terrible night's sleep where they periodically woke up their participants. Those who had been woken up, their IQ dropped on average 10 points the next day following sleep deprivation. It might seem small, but if that is a consistent impact that you are noticing caused by high cortisol, it's just going to feel like everything else is just a little bit harder.
你很暴躁，经常有一种轻微的易怒感，无法很好地处理信息，觉得自己反应迟钝。在2013年的一项研究中，研究人员观察了人们在睡了个好觉与睡了个糟糕的觉（研究人员定期叫醒参与者）之后的智商。那些被叫醒的人，在经历睡眠剥夺的第二天，智商平均下降了10分。这看起来可能微不足道，但如果这是由高皮质醇引起并被你注意到的持续影响，你就会觉得其他所有事情都变得稍微困难了一点。
this really does go to show it's not just about feeling more anxious. It's not just about feeling more stressed. It touches everything else in your life. It is in everything disorder or on everything experience. And I think I really feel, you know, I really feel for people who start to piece that together and realize that all of these interactions and things that are happening in their body link back to this stress response they can't control.
这确实表明，这不仅仅是感到更焦虑的问题，也不仅仅是感到压力更大的问题。它触及了你生活中的方方面面。它存在于每一个失调或每一种体验中。我想我真的很能理解那些开始把这些碎片拼凑起来，并意识到体内发生的所有这些相互作用和事情都追溯到他们无法控制的这种应激反应的人。
So we're going to talk about how to, navigate that, whether you're experiencing just low levels of stress, slightly elevated cortisol, or extremely high levels of cortisol, what are some of the lifestyle adjustments that might be recommended to you? I think if you're going to get tips on how to lower cortisol levels, the first people you want to talk to or hear from are doctors or an endocrinologist, basically that's a doctor who specializes in hormones and the endocrine system, hormones like cortisol. But before you get to that step, I do actually want you to make sure that what we're describing applies to you. There is a difference between
所以我们要讨论如何应对这种情况，无论你体验到的只是低水平的压力、稍微升高的皮质醇，还是极高水平的皮质醇，可能会向你推荐哪些生活方式的调整？我想，如果你想获得关于如何降低皮质醇水平的建议，你最想交谈或倾听的人是医生或内分泌学家，基本上内分泌学家就是专门研究荷尔蒙和内分泌系统的医生，比如皮质醇这样的荷尔蒙。但在你迈出这一步之前，我确实想确保我们所描述的情况适用于你。这其中是有区别的
heightened levels of stress, you know, that's short term and chronic stress that is causing elevated cortisol. And if you think that this applies to you, please go and see a doctor. They will be able to diagnose it for you. They will be able to really see what's happening below the surface through blood tests, through saliva tests. But I really think that cortisol dysregulation is not something you can say, oh yeah, I have that. That describes me. And I'm just going to go. with that diagnosis. Also because it can be linked back to really serious, serious problems like Cushing syndrome or tumours or problems with your pituitary glands. So if you are hearing this description being like, that's me. Oh my God, that's me. That's totally me. Go and speak to your doctor.
高度的压力，你知道的，那是短期的，还有导致皮质醇升高的慢性压力。如果你认为这适用于你，请去看医生。他们将能够为你诊断。他们将能够通过血液检查、唾液检查，真正了解表面之下的情况。但我真的认为皮质醇失调不是你可以随口说“哦，是的，我有这个，这描述了我，我将带着这个诊断离开”的事情。也因为它可能与真正严重的、严重的问题联系在一起，比如库欣综合征、肿瘤或垂体问题。所以如果你听到这个描述时觉得：那就是我，天哪，那就是我，完全是我。请去咨询你的医生。
I think whenever something blows up online or on social media like this idea of, you know, cortisol face and cortisol weight gain and is it high cortisol, we really do find it very easy. to see ourselves represented in people's descriptions. It's very easy to see something and say, oh my God, that's totally me. And that's because that's intentional from them. Like, they want you to engage with their content, so they're going to make it as general and broad as possible. And I'm sure their intentions are pure. And if they're trying to sell some tea or some supplement, maybe it did work from them. But your health is really such a valuable investment. And, you know, if you wouldn't want your mom or your sister or your brother or your partner getting all their
我想每当某种东西在网络或社交媒体上火起来，比如“皮质醇脸”、“皮质醇体重增加”以及“这是否是高皮质醇”这样的概念时，我们确实很容易在别人的描述中看到自己的影子。看到某种东西并说“天哪，这完全是我”是非常容易的。这是因为这是他们刻意为之的。他们希望你参与他们的内容，所以他们会使其尽可能通用和广泛。而且我确信他们的意图是纯粹的。如果他们试图卖点茶或某种补充剂，也许对他们来说确实管用。但你的健康确实是一项如此宝贵的投资，而且，你知道的，如果你不想让你的妈妈、姐姐、兄弟或伴侣从社交媒体上的人那里获取所有的
health advice from people on social media, don't do the same for yourself. People sharing their experiences is so valuable and it does help us become more educated about things that we didn't know about the human body or ourselves. But for something like cortisol dysregulation, make sure you get a doctor to confirm that. And with that in mind, that's where I sourced all my information from, specialized professionals because I understand cortisol from a psychological perspective, but how it impacts us biologically and how an endocrinologist or a doctor would recommend we address that, that really reigns supreme for me.
健康建议，也不要对自己这样做。人们分享他们的经验非常有价值，这确实有助于我们更多地了解我们以前不了解的人体或我们自己。但对于皮质醇失调这样的事情，请务必找医生来确认。带着这个想法，这也是我获取所有信息的来源，即专业人士，因为我从心理学的角度了解皮质醇，但它如何在生物学上影响我们，内分泌学家或医生会建议我们如何解决这个问题，这对我来说才是至高无上的。
Besides from addressing underlying medical conditions that are causing elevated cortisol and addressing those through a medical intervention, which Dar would be the first step, the biggest piece of advice I received for lowering stress and therefore lowering chronic over exposure to cortisol is to pursue balance, not extremes. Often, extremes are what cause chronic stress in the first place. Extreme work hours, extreme exercising in some instances, extreme relationships, extreme sleeping patterns. Your best bet for reversing the impact of high cortisol or chronic stress is to try and
除了解决导致皮质醇升高的潜在健康状况并通过医疗干预来解决这些状况（这当然是第一步），我收到的关于降低压力、从而降低对皮质醇长期过度暴露的最大建议是：追求平衡，而不是极端。通常，极端正是导致慢性压力的罪魁祸首。极端的工作时间，某些情况下的极端锻炼，极端的感情关系，极端的睡眠模式。扭转高皮质醇或慢性压力影响的最佳方法是尝试
return to your factory setting. to return to how you were made to operate as a human, as best as you can given your circumstances. What that means is get back to the most simplest foundations of health. Sleep, nutrition, safety, connection, outdoor time. Let's focus on sleep first. Obviously, we spoke about that morning anxiety and how sleep can be very heavily impacted by cortisol. But the tip that I heard that I thought was really, really amazing is that even if you are not asleep, try and be in bed for eight hours a day.
回归你的出厂设置。在你的情况下，尽你所能恢复到作为人类被创造出来的运作方式。这意味着回归最简单的健康基础：睡眠、营养、安全、连接、户外时间。让我们先把重点放在睡眠上。显然，我们讨论过晨间焦虑，以及睡眠如何受到皮质醇的极大影响。但我听到的一个建议，我认为真的非常惊艳，那就是：即使你没有睡着，也试着每天在床上躺八个小时。
Don't scroll, don't get up and watch TV just because your body isn't listening to you. Yes, you may have to lay in bed until 2 a.m. in the morning, but you're giving your body the best chance at rest it has. Around 40 to like 40 to 60 minutes before bed as well, reduce your exposure to bright and blue light. I personally did this. I was finding that I had my phone in my bedroom, so if I couldn't sleep after the first 10 minutes, I would get my phone. or I would watch Parks and Recreation or something like that. But I have since bought like an old fashioned alarm clock and it's been a game changer. It's been incredible. I spend less time in bed in the morning and my room is now associated with sleep.
不要刷手机，不要因为身体不听你的话就起床看电视。是的，你可能得在床上躺到凌晨两点，但你正在给你的身体提供它所能得到的最好的休息机会。在睡前大约40到60分钟，减少对亮光和蓝光的接触。我自己就这样做了。我发现我把手机放在卧室里，所以如果我在前10分钟后睡不着，我就会拿手机，或者我会看《公园与休憩》之类的节目。但后来我买了一个老式闹钟，这改变了一切。这太不可思议了。我早上在床上呆的时间变少了，我的房间现在和睡眠联系在了一起。
It's not just like some fun place to hang out. Like that's not where I go to scroll. That's not where I go to watch movies. Like that is my restful place and that is all that I want it to be kind of used for. Another basic to get back to is regular movement and movement in a way that you enjoy, not in a way you think you should be enjoying it or doing it. Now, there has been a lot of information going around that high intensity exercise should be avoided if you are trying to manage stress, mainly because of a finding from a 2008 paper that essentially claimed that intense exercise increased cortisol levels. Now, that paper was correct.
它不只是某个可以闲逛的好玩地方，那不是我去刷手机的地方，也不是我去电影院的地方，那是我获得休息的地方，这就是我希望它被用来做的一切。另一个要回归的基础是规律的运动，并且以你喜欢的方式运动，而不是以你认为自己应该喜欢或应该去做的方式运动。现在有很多信息流传开来，说如果你试图管理压力，就应该避免高强度运动，主要是因为2008年的一篇论文的一个发现，该论文基本上声称剧烈运动会增加皮质醇水平。现在，那篇论文是正确的。
It did increase cortisol levels. and it was actually published in the Journal of Endocrinological Investigation, so their findings were accurate. But those levels of cortisol actually ended up fading and reducing over the next four to six hours. And that's because exercise is a form of stress. It is stress on our bodies, but there is a difference between short-term stress and chronic long-term stress. Exercise triggers short-term stress, which does cause cortisol levels to rise, But actually, when we keep up with that regular movement and exercise, our body learns how to regulate those spikes and cortisol fluctuations. And so it becomes better able to regulate cortisol in general.
它确实增加了皮质醇水平，而且它实际上发表在《内分泌学调查杂志》上，所以他们的发现是准确的。但这些皮质醇水平在接下来的四到六小时内实际上最终会消退和减少。这是因为运动是一种压力，它是对我们身体的压力，但短期压力和长期慢性压力是有区别的。运动会引发短期压力，这确实会导致皮质醇水平上升，但实际上，当我们坚持规律的运动和锻炼时，我们的身体学会了如何调节这些峰值和皮质醇波动。因此，它总体上变得更能调节皮质醇了。
So although, yes, you might experience a small spike in cortisol after you exercise, you'll also experience a spike in endorphins. You'll also feel more relaxed. And so it actually is for the better. obviously if you are exercising at 90% effort seven days a week you are not giving your body a chance to repair and balance things out but pursuing the kind of movement that our ancestors would is really beneficial moderate exercise movement in whatever form works best for you walking lifting the way we would have lifted fallen trees children rocks like i know it sounds so rudimentary and basic but if it's gotten us to where we are as a species where we are now and if that's how our bodies were designed to operate. I'm just assuming that that kind of movement is really what our body is asking for. The next focus is what we're putting into our body. The biggest one being caffeine. I'm sorry if that's not what you wanted to hear, but truly, caffeine is not doing you any favors. So I haven't drunk coffee or really caffeine really for almost four years at this point. Maybe I'll have the occasional
所以，虽然是的，你在运动后可能会经历皮质醇的小幅飙升，但你也会经历内啡肽的飙升，你也会感到更加放松。所以这实际上是为了更好。显然，如果你每周七天以90%的努力锻炼，你根本没有给你的身体一个修复和平衡的机会，但追求我们祖先那种形式的运动真的很有益。适度的运动，以最适合你的任何形式行走，搬运我们以前搬运过的倒伏树木、儿童、岩石——我知道这听ing起来很原始和基础，但如果它让我们作为一个物种走到了今天这个地步，如果我们当时的身体就是被设计成那样运作的，我只是假设这种运动确实是我们的身体所要求的。下一个重点是我们摄入身体的东西。其中最大的一项就是咖啡因。如果这不是你想听到的，我很抱歉，但真的，咖啡因对你没有任何好处。所以我几乎四年没有喝过咖啡或真正的咖啡因了。也许我会偶尔喝一杯
diet coke because I can't be helped but I noticed such a huge shift in alertness, energy levels and anxiety. I was so reliant on caffeine to make me alert and then I would basically just allow it would make me alert and then I would obviously it would fade away and I'd feel less alert and then I'd make myself alert again and you know by the time that I was ready for sleep hopefully the caffeine had faded like it was really controlling my energy levels and And with that, it was artificially controlling my anxiety and stress levels. Like the times that I felt most stressed in my day or in my week were the times when I had consumed the most caffeine, thinking that it was going to help me be more productive.
健怡可乐，因为我无可救药，但我注意到警觉性、能量水平和焦虑状况发生了巨大的转变。我太依赖咖啡因来让我保持清醒，然后我基本上只是允许它让我清醒，然后它显然会消退，我会觉得没那么清醒，然后我就会让自己再次清醒，你知道的，当我准备好睡觉的时候，希望咖啡因已经消退了——它真的在控制我的能量水平，随之而来的是，它在人为地控制我的焦虑和压力水平。比如我一天或一周中感觉压力最大的时候，正是我摄取了最多咖啡因的时候，当时我还以为它会帮我提高效率。
But actually, it just made me feel more jittery. It made me feel more, almost like unstable in a way. Like every single thought just felt a little bit too loud and a little bit too urgent. And when I eventually quit, I found that I was so tired. for the first two weeks. Like I cannot explain how tired I was. But then I was actually able to regulate energy using routine and actually utilizing like the natural circadian rhythm and flow of my day and my wakefulness versus sleepy hours
但实际上，它只是让我感到更加神经过敏。它让我感觉更紧张，几乎以一种不稳定的方式。就像每一个想法都感觉声音太大了，太迫切了。当我最终戒掉它时，我发现我在前两周里是如此疲惫。我无法形容我有多累。但随后我实际上能够通过规律来调节能量，并真正利用我一天中自然的昼夜节律、流动以及清醒与睡眠时间
and noticing like peak kind of like peak hard work times or like peak inspiration, motivation, focus times for myself and it was a really important change. A 2008 study also showed caffeine stimulates cortisol secretion. No matter how much caffeine you consume as well, you were never able to build up a tolerance enough that it would stop cortisol spikes from happening. So if you are sitting there being like, I'm so stressed, I'm so anxious and you have not cut out caffeine, if you haven't gone teacath, if you haven't gone for a tea, if you haven't cut down to just one coffee a day, please, before you consume a supplement, before you try and do
并注意到我自己处于高强度工作的高峰期，或者灵感、动力、专注力的高峰期，这是一个非常重要的改变。2008年的一项研究还表明，咖啡因会刺激皮质醇分泌。无论你消耗多少咖啡因，你永远无法建立足够的耐受力来阻止皮质醇峰值的发生。所以如果你坐在那里说：我很压力，我很焦虑，而你还没有戒掉咖啡因，如果你没有改喝茶，如果你没有减少到一天只喝一杯咖啡，求求你，在你服用补充剂之前，在你尝试
crazy ice plunges for your anxiety, just try it and see if it works. The next best tip that you will hear is to spend more time outside. Nature is where your stress response is meant to operate, and so it is there that it will be best regulated. I'm going to say one more time, nature was where your stress response was meant to operate, so it's there that it can be regulated. Time and time again, you will see studies showing us that nature has a positive effect on stress by reducing cortisol levels, even if it's just for 20 to 30 minutes a day. That's the time it would take to eat your lunch outside. Or if it's really cold where you are, eat your lunch next to a window so that you can just see nature,
疯狂的冰浴来治疗你的焦虑之前，先试一试，看看它是否管用。你将听到的下一个最好的建议是花更多的时间在户外。大自然是你的应激反应本该运作的地方，因此正是在那里它能得到最好的调节。我要再说一遍，大自然是你的应激反应本该运作的地方，所以正是在那里它才能得到调节。一次又一次，你会看到研究表明，大自然通过降低皮质醇水平对压力产生积极影响，即使每天只有20到30分钟。那是你在户外吃午饭所需的时间。或者如果所在地真的很冷，就在窗户旁边吃午饭，这样你就能看到大自然，
even if you can't be in it. Some scientists like to call it the nature pill because they have suggested that outdoor time, like what we used to have as children, should be something that they can prescribe to people. You know, people who live very busy urban lives could be prescribed, like a 30-minute nature prescription the same way that they would be prescribed antibiotics or painkillers. Hopefully, so they take it seriously. So they finally realize that it should be a priority, that this will help you, that this is actually a researched and necessary medical intervention.
即使你不能身处其中。一些科学家喜欢称它为“大自然药丸”，因为他们建议户外时间，就像我们小时候那样，应该成为他们可以给人们开出的处方。你知道的，生活在非常繁忙的城市生活中的人们可以开具30分钟的大自然处方，就像他们被开具抗生素或止痛药一样。希望这样他们能认真对待。希望他们最终意识到这应该是一个优先事项，这会对你有所帮助，这实际上是一项经过研究且必要的医疗干预。
One study found that people who made nature a daily priority for themselves saw salivatory cortisol levels and self-reported stress dropped by almost half from what they were previously experiencing. But it is a practice that we largely ignore because we have become so detached from our natural habitat as mammals and as humans. Another resource that you have at your disposal right now, much like nature, is your breath. It is the tool of meditators worldwide for good reason because controlled breathing helps stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system. That's known as our rest and digest system compared to our fight or flight system, and our fight or flight system is what activates cortisol release.
一项研究发现，那些将大自然作为日常优先事项的人，其唾液皮质醇水平和自我报告的压力比以前下降了近一半。但这是一种我们很大程度上忽视的做法，因为我们作为哺乳动物和人类，已经与我们的自然栖息地脱节了。你现在掌握的另一个资源，就像大自然一样，是你的呼吸。它是世界各地冥想者的工具，这是有充分理由的，因为控制呼吸有助于刺激你的副交感神经系统。这被称为我们的休息和消化系统，与我们的战斗或逃跑系统相对，而我们的战斗或逃跑系统会激活皮质醇的释放。
So activating your rest and digest system is the counterbalance that you need. You have probably already heard of a lot of the breathing exercises that people recommend belly breathing in particular. If you've done a yoga class, you'll be for. familiar with this. It's the four in, hold for four, six out kind of breathing. So breathe in for four, hold your breath for four, breathe out for six, where you're kind of focused on feeling your body expand, like there's a big cloud filling up that space. So if you feel your, you know, energy levels and your stress levels rising in response to a deadline or something in your environment or just something you can't put your finger on, try this technique and try it as a way to get in front of
所以激活你的休息和消化系统正是你需要的平衡力量。你可能已经听说过人们推荐的很多呼吸练习，特别是腹式呼吸。如果你上过瑜伽课，你就会对此很熟悉。这就是“吸气四秒，憋气四秒，呼气六秒”的那种呼吸。所以吸气四秒，憋气四秒，呼气六秒，这时你专注于感受你的身体膨胀，就像有一大朵云在填满那个空间。所以如果你觉得你的能量水平和压力水平在响应截止日期、环境中的某事或某种你无法确切指出的东西时上升，请尝试这种技术，并尝试将其作为一种领先于
your stress and then later on respond more appropriately. There are other natural remedies as simple as nature and breathing itself that are important. Laughter, tending to your spirituality, spending time alone, giving yourself silent and alone space and time. All really important for chronic stress. Looking after a pet, looking after others. Great for managing. anxiety and worry. Mainly, I think that what I would want to impress on people, particularly those of us in our 20s, is that we are told, especially in this day and age,
你的压力的方法，然后在稍后做出更恰当的反应。还有其他像大自然和呼吸本身一样简单的自然疗法，它们同样重要。大笑、关注你的精神世界、独自呆着、给自己留出安静独处的空间和时间。对慢性压力都非常重要。照顾宠物，照顾他人。非常适合管理焦虑和担忧。主要是，我想给人们留下深刻印象的是，特别是我们这些二十多岁的人，我们被告知，尤其是在这个时代，
that pushing ourselves, being disciplined, sacrificing for success, is going to give you the happiest and most fulfilled life you could ask for. It's going to give you wealth, it's going to give you accomplishment, praise, achievement. And yes, pushing yourself, maybe we'll get you those things, but if your body is under immense chronic stress in order to get there, I don't think one part of it will be worth it.
推动自己、保持纪律、为成功牺牲，会给你带来你能要求的最高兴、最充实的生活。它会给你带来财富、成就、赞美、成就。是的，推动自己，也许会给你带来那些东西，但如果你的身体为了到达那里而承受着巨大的慢性压力，我认为其中的任何一部分都不值得。
You won't be able to enjoy it. You won't feel good. Your body will literally become sick. It will crumble. It will feel terrible. You will feel miserable because you have neglected your physical and mental health to get to that point. I think what's even more important to notice that high levels of stress from lifestyle factors like overworking, they are going to make it harder for you to focus.
你将无法享受它。你不会感觉良好。你的身体字面意义上会生病。它会崩溃。感觉会糟糕透顶。你会感到痛苦，因为你为了达到那个目标而忽视了你的身心健康。我认为更重要的是要注意到，来自过度工作等生活方式因素的高压力水平将使你更难以集中注意力。
They impact executive functioning, mental clarity, brain. health, motivation. So pace yourself. Go slow. Take time for rest and to nurture your body. And I actually think that it helps you get to the place or to your achievements in a more sustainable and therefore faster way. And in a way that by the time you get there, you can actually enjoy them rather than feeling like just everything around you is crumbling. And suddenly you've gotten to where you want to be and you have to take time off just to get the basics down pat and look half to yourself. So I don't think anything should cost you your health. It's not worth it. It's so hard to recover. So take care of yourself and recognize chronic stress as just as of a
它们会影响执行功能、精神清晰度、大脑健康、动力。所以放慢节奏。放慢脚步。抽出时间休息并滋养你的身体。我实际上认为这有助于你以一种更可持续、因此也更快的方式到达那个地方或实现你的目标。而且以这样一种方式：当你到达那里时，你实际上可以享受它们，而不是觉得你周围的一切都在崩溃。突然之间，你已经到达了你想去的地方，却不得不休假来把基础打好，照顾好自己。所以我不认为任何事情应该以牺牲你的健康为代价。这不值得。恢复起来太难了。所以照顾好自己，并承认慢性压力就像
risk to your health as anything else that you would be scared of, as smoking, as loneliness, as dangerous driving even. So I hope this episode has helped you. I hope that you have learned more about the impact, the hidden impact of cortisol. We've myth busted some of the beliefs that some people hold about cortisol being bad, that you shouldn't exercise intensely, that you shouldn't eat certain foods because they're bad for you that this can only be cured by supplements, whatever it is. Hopefully you have a better, more clear understanding. If you did enjoy this episode, make sure you follow along on Spotify or Apple Podcasts, leave a five-star review, leave a comment as well if you made it this far.
你害怕的任何其他事情一样，对你的健康构成了风险：就像吸烟、孤独、甚至是危险驾驶。所以我希望这一集对你有所帮助。我希望你对皮质醇的影响、隐藏的影响有了更多的了解。我们打破了一些人对皮质醇不好的某些信念，比如你不应该剧烈运动，你不应该吃某些食物因为它们对你不好，这只能通过补充剂来治疗，无论是什么。希望你有一个更好、更清晰的理解。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请确保在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上关注我们，留下五星好评，如果你听到了这里，也请留个言。
I love engaging with you guys all that way and get in to respond to you all and see what you've felt about this episode and make sure you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast to see further tips behind the scenes stuff and also some infographics about this episode. Until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, manage your stress and we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that, you're listening to
我喜欢以这种方式与你们所有人互动，并能够回复你们所有人，看看你们对这一集的感受，并确保你们在Instagram上关注我们@thatpsychology podcast，以查看更多的幕后花絮以及关于这一集的图表。下次见，注意安全，善待他人，对温柔对待自己，管理好你的压力，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，你在听的
It's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular.
去任何地方真的都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？这向世界发出了一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你捏造了这个特定的
test twice in this Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
测试两次，在欧文斯案中，对吗？我捏造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的模式。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑爆炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
收听《2%》。即TWO.%在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或无论你在哪里获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends, trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is a... IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《女朋友们，相信我，宝贝》。这是一个...IHeart播客。保证由人类创作。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。